[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من
جناح مستوحى من الماوري النيوزيلندي الأصلي إلى الهيكل الخفيف في فرنسا
مع ستة أشهر للذهاب لأعمال البناء
لمعرض إكسبو
2020 ، يجري الانتهاء من أكثر من 190
جناحًا ريفيًا
ويتم الكشف عن بعضها
[موسيقى]
من بين الأحدث استثمارًا في فرنسا بقيمة 30 مليون
دولار والذي سيعرض
الابتكار
والتكنولوجيا الفرنسية ، تنفق دول أخرى
مبالغ مماثلة
في استثمار باهظ التكلفة حيث
يتصارع العالم مع الانكماش الاقتصادي ،
وأعتقد أن الاستثمار فيما يتعلق
بالنتائج ليس
مهمًا جدًا لأننا متأكدون  أنه في
هذه الفترة المحددة بعد أزمة 19 covet ،
لدينا الفرصة للقيام ببعض
الشبكات
لإظهار مواهبنا ومنتجاتنا خدماتنا يعد
معرض ابتكاراتنا أو المعرض العالمي أحد أقدم
الأحداث في العالم
في أوجها ، فقد جلب لنا اختراعات
مثل  ماكينة الخياطة
بالهاتف اللاسلكي وحتى الكاتشب
لكنها لا تزال ذات صلة اليوم نعم
لأننا لدينا  اعتبرنا هذا الجناح كجناح
مستدام وهو
بالنسبة لنا وسيلة لإظهار
ما تستطيع فرنسا القيام به في أفضل حالاته
وهو أحد أهداف
إكسبو كيف يمكن لجميع البلدان
المساهمة
في هذا المعرض العالمي المستدام والعادل الجديد
2020 هو رهان بقيمة سبعة مليارات دولار من
قبل دبي على
أن الحدث سيعزز الاهتمام بالسياحة والأعمال
، ولهذا السبب استثمرت نيوزيلندا أكثر
من 40 مليون دولار في جناحها ،
سيكون هذا في عالم ما بعد التغطية
فرصة لنيوزيلندا لإعادة الاتصال
مع  لقد حققنا
أداءً جيدًا مع بعض أسواق التصدير لدينا ،
ولكن الآن هي فرصة
للتأكد من أننا ندخل
مساحات جديدة ورفع ملفنا الشخصي حقًا ،
كان من المتوقع أن يحضر أكثر من 25 مليون زائر
معرض إكسبو 2020 مع هذه الأرقام التي يحتمل أن تكون
موضع شك بسبب  من
البلدان المشاركة في الوباء العالمي مثل الفرنسيين
ما زالوا يأملون في
أن يكون هناك الكثير من
الفرص لدفع
الأعمال والتجارة العالمية.